I've seen the barking dog' probably a
hundred times maybe more and I never
noticed this before because it's just
too fast for the eye to see
this reaction is one of a real favorites
it's been carried out for many years as
a demonstration to our students and
particularly by myself and some of my
colleagues but also by BD Shaw Colonel
Shaw who used to do the thunder and
lightning lecture many many times and
apply alike it's called the barking dog
it produces quite a kind of a backing
dog sound a wolf sound it involves a
test tube a really big test tube this is
just a model with a cork and inside is a
mixture of carbon disulfide cs2 and n2o
nitrous oxide the flame shoots out the
top of the test tube so I guess you have
this image of this this flame coming up
and consuming your hand if you leave it
over the top of the test tube too long
my first few goals always quite you can
see me flinching and in some of the
videos but I am as I've done it now
probably tens if not hundreds of times I
flinch less and less the combustion
front races to the bottom of the tube
giving up this amazing whoop and
normally what the audience sees is a
great rush the note just goes up like
the squeak I made then it can be drawn
out it could be roof or sometimes it
goes much quicker but when you watch it
in slow motion it looks quite different
now you may not seen exactly what
happened what I observed was it although
the flame started slowly it built up the
speed as it went off I've never seen it
using this really really ultra fast
camera you still see the flame going
down instead of going down in one great
whoosh it jumps up and down the tube so
it goes down a little bit and then up
and down and up and down and so on and
as it gets near at the bottom it seems
to go up and down more and more okay so
we take the top off without a match and
I thought that this this this flame
front used to go very very smoothly from
the top to the bottom and hence the
whoop but actually what this video
footage is shown us is that it actually
goes in stages it's sort of good sort of
chugs its way to the bottom of the tube
we weren't quite sure what was happening
I think what's happening is the pressure
wave is bouncing off the bottom of the
tube now a number of very curious things
are going on in this to imagine this
hand here the one with the watch is the
flame front coming down and as it comes
down it gradually goes faster as it
heats up and burns the fuel and
eventually gets the stage where it
almost explodes and sends a shock wave
down to the bottom of the tube when it
gets the bottle the tube it can't go any
further it's not strong enough to break
the glass the only time it ever went
wrong for me was we broke the bottom of
the glass so I guess that the pressure
pushed that the tube downwards and we
broke the top off the end and I only
know of that happening once and it
happened to me so it's reflected and
comes up again and then when it gets the
flame it gives it a push upwards so the
flame is now burning up here where there
isn't quite so much fuel and it
gradually warms up again till it gets
here where the fuel is rich and then
another shockwave good boom up
and actually if you look really
carefully it looks like it's picking up
speed as it goes down the tube and I
think that's because the distance
between the the flame and the bottom of
the tube is getting smaller and smaller
each time
boom cup till in the end is going really
quite fast well we still have another
Joule prepared and so you have another
opportunity of observing this effect
I've seen two or three Vulcan dog
experiments since then but the flame
front going down is really too fast to
see this bouncing and anyway I'm too
busy blocking my ears to really pay
attention to the flame front
I think of all the slow motions that
I've watched that one was the most
surprising because you could have
expected that cesium or rubidium would
cause a big explosion but none of us
really expected this motion of the flame
front I suppose once you've seen it you
can think of an explanation it's no
longer such a surprise but none of us
were expecting it okay PhD is in some of
these speakers every time you do a new
experiment you see something subtly
different and not just ask it makes you
ask more questions
red circle red said oh yeah
ready on the trigger ready yeah